and typical points antipodal points or
also called just Antipodes edges are
points that the supervisor can set is
are on exactly the opposite sides of a
sphere their points a pair of points
that are owned exactly the opposite
sides of a sphere so for example you all
know there's a famous pair of antipodal
points one on the top the North Pole and
one on the bottom of the earth the South
Pole for the sake of simplicity we won't
worry about the fact that there's
different poles is like magnetic poles
and then there's compasses anyway we
will consider one North Pole one South
Pole they are directly facing away from
each other another way of saying this is
if you're watching join these two points
if you were to join any two and two
points what you'll find is that they
pass directly through the center of the
sphere so what you got is a diameter
right any edge of reports will do this
the interval between the will pass
through the center and it will be a
diameter so if that's what an atypical
point or that's what editing words are
how do you find them if they're not so
easy like the North and South Pole for
instance if I said I'll put it here I
guess if I said there was a point on the
surface of the earth what does that look
like I don't know I'd say something like
35 degrees north
so there's your latitude and let's just
say it's 110 degrees east
there's your longitude how will you go
about working the antipodal point for
this have a think about it so you want
this on the opposite side of the earth
or the opposite side we'll take a one
step at a time let's think about the
latitude first and then we'll get on to
the longitude if this is from the
equator right and from the Sun yep from
the centre you've measured up
35 degrees okay if you want a spot on
the exact opposite side of the earth
which actually you're going to go in
you're going to go south and how far
will you go
you will also go 35 degrees after that
oh so you can see it's through on the
other side of the earth naturally if
this was closer to the equator something
like say 10 degrees off that you would
only have to go 10 degrees south to be
on the exact opposite
latitude now let's think about longitude
this is a little bit trickier 110
degrees 30 degrees if you were to go on
the other side of the earth how many
degrees would you rotate through to the
only exact opposite side to end up to
measure all the way it'll be 180 degrees
right which is why there's the Prime
Meridian on one side and if you go all
the way back around
it's 180 East to 180 Wes okay so think
about this we need to go 180 degrees in
either direction
this is 110 degrees east 110 degrees
east of what of the prime meridian of
the Greenwich longitude right so if I
were to travel which direction do I need
to travel in to get to Greenwich so this
means east of the Prime Meridian does
this make sense
so here's Greenwich you travel 110
degrees east and then you'll get to this
spot does that make sense so to get back
to Greenwich you're going to have to
travel 110 degrees west to come back to
Greenwich and you've already traveled
110 degrees so how much further you have
to go 17 does that make sense so you've
gone all the way around 110 Plus 70 that
gives you or 180 which makes you on the
opposite side of the world just that
make sense
okay so let's experiment with this right
we're suggesting if this is a let's call
that a if B is
the end tippity or the end typical point
for a it is at we already worked out
okay you're going to go down that way so
35 degrees south and then we said okay
well let's get to the activity by
spinning all the way around the world
but passing through Greenwich okay the
reason why I pass through Greenwich is
everything is measured in relation to
Greenwich it's just going to be easier
that way so I'm currently 110 degrees
east I'm going to travel west to
Greenwich and then further to get to the
opposite side of the world which will
give me 70 degrees
West because I travel west that whole
time does that make sense okay so there
we go
does it always work well let's think
about this let's pick another point
speak another point let's pick on in the
southern hemisphere let's pick one quite
close to the South Pole so give me a
latitude that might be close to the
South Pole what is the latitude is that
pole area it's lady right because you're
measuring from the center so 90 will be
all the way so maybe something close to
that is something might say 80 how about
that that's that's going to be an
Antarctic Circle is there such a thing
anyway so you've gone eighty degrees
down okay let's call this guy
I called that a and B so let's call this
C and we'll get an typical point called
beep if C is at 80 degrees south and
let's give it some other longitude what
would you like me to pick something west
hey should we do something West how bout
this is a big angle how about 37 degrees
west let's just call it there okay let's
think about the antipodal point for C
it's on the opposite side so let's think
about latitude first you're down the
bottom here in the southern hemisphere
did you notice the ante one will always
be in the opposite hemisphere unless of
course you're on the equator because
then you're not honor in either ahem
uses so where will I be I'll be 80
degrees
right I'm going to be you can literally
see the line going up through the air
right so you're going to be D will be at
eighty degrees north okay now let's
think about this you're on the hour
actually can enjoy this because I'm
waving my arms around too much you are
are 37 degrees west right now of
Greenwich okay so if I say let's make
the Prime Meridian here I'm drawing to
the west so that's to the left right
over here that's where C is somewhere on
this line
okay so I've gone 37 degrees west so to
get to the opposite side of the world
the antipodal point I'm going to have to
travel east that 37 and then I'm going
to travel east a further amount to make
it 180
what will the further about be a hundred
and forty three degrees east of the
Prime Meridian does that make sense do
you see what's going on there so if you
go all the way from C to D you've
traveled 180 degrees that puts you on
the opposite side so far so good
so it's 140 degrees and you can see what
direction I'm facing in so I'll go back
and come now this is 143 degrees east
make sense you're happy
so think about longitude and latitude
carefully and always think about a
picture of don't have to be a beautiful
picture just enough so that you can work
out some corner time any questions about
that I made it up I just picked a point
on the earth yeah so if this is where
your original point is this is where
your entity will be so one of the things
that you can see if you look carefully
look for a pattern right see this guy
and this guy what's the relationship 110
and 70 they're supplementary they add to
a hundred eighty and the same pattern is
here you see they add to one 180 it's
just they're on opposite sides we don't
tend to talk about eastern or western
hemispheres but I suppose if you did
that's what that refers to
okay